that's it man that's it that's it as a
mmm the elevators boy we elevators we
are elevators some people stop some
people never make it off the ground
floor some people they don't really have
that they don't have that that rise and
I'm that lift you know everybody has a
buddy who's just a he's an elevator but
he's just only in the parking garage you
know he ain't even making it to the
lobby at a building but where elevators
man and some people their elevator it's
out of service
sometime you meet someone and I mean
they should just have a sign on me you
know that ain't ain't going anywhere so
but we on the rise baby you know that
[Music]
I'm just sitting on your front porch
wondering how could I be so far oh and I
was far from my home but your rope and
my mind is somewhere else but when I
found it I'll patch up where it's been
grown now I'm just on the breeze and I
must be
[Music]
for me to set that parking brake
[Music]
[Music]
and way too fast on a runaway train with
a heavy level of mine
[Music]
okay okay okay
oh yeah and no in the world sometimes
the world you just that globe you want
to slow that globe baby sometime you
want to slow that globe I'm back I'm
back from Europe Europe my up our up and
Europe if you don't know what Europe is
that's that original America if you go
over there some places especially
Britain United Britain Kingdom I mean
they chant they got so many names for
that place is wild England brittle and
Scotland north Scotland Wales Celtics
Rangers it's dude Willie Wallace's over
there and he'd um he done closed down
his sherwin-williams buying all the baby
blue face paint and they I mean it's I'm
good to be back and it was a it was a
give us quite a journey it was a great
time it was I'm gonna tell you about it
what happened man
yeah dude if you don't know about
Britain or it's basically it's kind of
like if say if America had like you went
over to your grandparents house and they
had a bunch of stuff in the attic and
they got like a lot of like a glass like
a case with a lot of fancy [ __ ] in it
like a lot of fancy um silverwares and
special spoons you sometimes your
grandmother will have like a little
shiver robe with some glass doors on it
some just straight up lying the Witch
and the Wardrobe type of deal and inside
of it she'll have 30 spoons in there
wouldn't the hell is this
she you know she freebasing and she you
know cooking up that smack it what's
going on grandma and that is a little
bit like britain it's kind of like your
grandparents house they got a lot of
fancy old stuff they have you just like
a lot of like you'll see a guy walking
by he'll have on chain mail
you know he'll have a scroll he'll have
something from you don't even know how
long ago it's from you know you'll see
somebody they're eating food you know
they're 83 they're having like a 400
year old aged steak like damn an estate
what is that is that triceratop what is
that you know they it's just it's yeah
it's like going to your grandparents
they got all the old they got a picture
of oh dude on the ball with a sword like
who was that you know Jerry sword who
was that [ __ ] Pocahontas bruh who is
it that dude's got that thigh needle bro
he have that foot that's so word right
there ready to take somebody's eye out
or whatever do a shish kebab do the
onion and the meat but man I had a great
time I'm gonna take you through a little
bit of the journey of the journey yeah
let me start off we'll start off with
you know where it was London
Britain
[Music]
[Music]
and that's a little bit of British theme
music right there and as you can tell
from the music the theme is nap time
probably Britain okay we started off we
went over to Manchester and I don't know
who this Manchester is bruh but he he is
pretty much a lot of the in Britain are
like more you you know you know
everybody the real kind of well first of
all man Britain England has some of and
I say this with love I really do cuz I
thought a lot about it
England obtained somehow some of the
worst looking women I've ever seen in my
life
dude I look I love and man is hurt hurts
me to say it but some of the women
you're like dude no wonder they I if I
if those were the women I had to be
around visually I would go around and
enslave the rest of the world they need
a couple of bad batches shipped in over
there it just uh yeah you I mean they
just think some of the women you like Oh
dying you a woman oh man I think that's
the real reason if it's if if we could
dig up a couple of these pilgrims and do
a seance on them you know put that Ouija
on them bro throw a couple of magic
rocks on their back or whatever or smoke
a bowl out of their skull and get their
ideas we would know for a fact that the
real reason
that the pilgrims left England whenever
it was 1300 whatever a thousand whatever
was because they heard there was some
tan [ __ ] has over there in North
America some of those land [ __ ] bro
you know what I'm saying
some of those outdoor [ __ ]
you know what I'm talking about Indians
dude Native Americans because the women
they just they God brah I would start a
war with somebody too if those were the
women I had I'd start a war I'd go warn
for women I'd roll a cannon down at a
frickin straight over to the to the
females in a different country and I'd
fight anybody that wanted me to not have
those women because these ladies some of
them there Jamie Venegas
they look kind of I don't knows and then
in Britain the people a lot of them real
and look thank you guys thank you guys
for coming out van Chester you guys
showed out and this was now this I
started in Manchester bro and so in
Manchester I don't even know how the
place got started probably this man you
know he just said hey I'm us chill right
here if you don't want to be here with
me and everybody was like all right
Chester bro we'll do it so but yeah the
women brought a just little they're all
real kind of little and their legs they
don't have all their whole body seem to
look like a but their whole body seemed
like a little like a like a kind of us
like a strong little but like a little
uh like imagine if somebody had but all
their body you know they just covered up
in that frickin cheek meat you know and
when they walk you but like even when
they wave at you to see that ass shake a
little bit on their forearm everywhere
they smile him like dang they got that
smile and asked me face kinda and that's
you know how it was they just that's
what it was like over there and and in
England a lot people are just kind of
like me know Oh II and everybody I call
them the white Japanese man because the
British they're very traditional okay
you have ton of tradition you have a lot
of I think kind of inner turmoil and
like inner kind of pain and there's a
lot of like family name honor and they
kind of keep things chill until they get
drunk and then they lose that absolutely
lose their [ __ ] and they turn red and
basically that's the jet that's the
white Japanese very to me they have that
they had that white Japanese II kind of
feel like I bet at night secretly a lot
of British people put on karate suits
because they know in their heart and
deep down in their bone marrow where
they are really from and they are the
white Japan and everything is putting
that's what they have for I don't know
what it is you want to boring Britain
pudding man blood pudding pudding
pudding pudding mister mister pudding
and some of the ladies look like them
they had about seven thousand servings
of pudding dude and they just look like
a pudding in a boot I mean yeah oh man I
feel so ice cold and look I'll say this
I knew that the women were good-looking
when I was getting hit on I was probably
one of the I would say 7000 best-looking
women in England when I was there bro
gang though yeah but with that set man
ah yeah we got to man chair and it just
was you know really glum there's a lot
of like like Eeyore is probably from
there from the Paddington Winnie the
Pooh you know where's Monty that guy you
know probably that some older fling
Blaine Kaiser blade that do swing blade
probably would be the mayor over there
because it's got that real zombie knots
you know it don't have him much Tom be
honest it's got that um be nots like
ambiance is like and that was the start
we started off in Manchester but the
shows were good the show it was you know
it says starter when I'm starting
something up is you know it's like you
know to go somewhere and you get off the
jet and the plane and the people and you
got to do it you're like damn I gotta do
it still but the crowd was real nice
supportive and and I didn't change much
material I would kind of try and talk
about the area little but since I just
got there Manchester there wasn't
anything to discuss yet because I was
fresh to the gate and I was fresh to the
gate bruh like that freaking lettuce
though and then we went to hold on I
know where we went to Ireland
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and that's some Irish music right there
and that is from a group called rune
Dale Irene doll and Ireland's showed out
this was I think a Monday night in
Dublin we had two shows and they the
Irish I got this jacket I got this soft
jacket from they're from Trinity College
and we went into Trinity College in
Dublin and they have the oldest library
this is like where Hogwarts keeps its
hogs you know this thing old I mean some
of the books you open it up doing your
great-grandfather's in there
you know washing his legs in a bucket
like damn this thing old do you open one
book in st. Peter's in there reading an
even older book dude opened up one book
bro it had time in it you know timbre
from the beginning of time it's just if
I have fallen out Dewey Decimal was
there he was there man he had hurt his
leg but he was there and we went into
this library and it's the oldest library
I think in like in earth and playing on
earth they haven't found anything else
that's older and it's priceless they
said the value of the books in there
priceless
Trinity College the library's at and you
can even go and check the books out I
mean if you were if something happens to
one of them you're you know you're gonna
work there for the rest of your life but
you could go check it out but what
happened yeah people came out in Ireland
brought oh do a guy brought me some
great art it's all it's like great and
not great you know it's kind of this
young artist bro McCloskey this is the
boy's name and yeah and yeah I mean it
just once you go from England
Ireland you get a bit more the
traditions a little bit different the
tradition gets a little more I would say
alcoholic you know people's just you
know and they just feeling they just
they I don't know there's a lot more
it's just more whimsical you know you'll
see a dude just walk you know washing
using a nice bar of soap over there like
in a puddle you're like all right and
they're tough people there to the real
you'll see a baby I saw a baby getting
pushed in a little carriage bro you know
and he and it was windy I mean they
probably had 30 mile-per-hour winds just
right on the street and this baby's
whole head just just really chill he
could you could tell he was he was just
toughing it out though that's the Irish
bro they tough it out this baby had a
little rusted in his job bro you know he
had a [ __ ] half a kilo of PO Todd and
his cheek and he was just tatarin
against the cold just yeah and his mom
is just pushing him and you can tell
this baby he was gonna you know and
nothing would stop him for the rest of
his life because he was he was dealing
with it alright now I mean when you 11
months old and you going straight face
to face against 30 mile-per-hour winds I
don't even think the baby had a damn hat
on or anything he had a diaper II had a
very strong diaper and and a baby
honestly might have had a tattoo man the
Irish are wild and they're real pale too
so I mean I'm kind you know I'm racist
but I mean [ __ ] Irish races dude that
those do as soon as you see them you
liked him I'm white but this white bruh
dude they really they whitened it up
what else yeah but that baby you'll see
the mom will just if the baby gets too
he can't handle
the elements the mother you'll see him
the mother lick his cheeks and wetting
them up you know were just lick his eyes
shut real quick but let the baby get
some rest
but in Dublin man the people were great
and it was just a lot of like kind of
stop and go was like you go you get to
the place you get some food you get and
then and then you get moving and then
you get going to the next place oh I saw
Prince Harry and Megan they left and if
you don't know about it then you can
know about it right now Prince Harry and
Megan left and that's so wild I if I was
a prince would I just they gave up the
titles kind of and they moved to Canada
and America been even really roughing it
you want to rough it give up the titles
move to Serbia and Montenegro dog you
know you want to rough it move to UM you
know st. Louis and Afghanistan you know
but giving up the titles would you give
up the titles the titles are kind of
old-fashioned I guess I mean I think
that some of the thing is crazy I mean I
don't know I don't know man I got a lot
of schools sometimes I wish we had a
king you know I wish we just voted and
we just had this kind of strange dude
wandering around in a building somewhere
you know in practice and jousting is
[ __ ] like that and doing thumbs-up or
thumbs-down
every time I knew our bad boys movie
comes out so you know if you have to see
it or not and then they you know but
yeah they're giving up the titles man if
I was a prince would I give that up
but Harry was the wild Harry was always
the wild one he was in the military he
seemed like the cool cat you know he had
his wiener out in Vegas dude that's a
regular guy I mean he'll he could be
President next you know in two terms it
makes you kind of the lady they got the
baby yeah I'm saying if you're gonna
give up the title so they're gonna still
be I think they kind of just didn't want
to live at the house that's what it
sounds like they wanted to get out of
London they wanted to get into maybe
something just more of an adventure kind
of and plus his brother Charlie is the
yeah Harry's the Duke I think yeah the
other boys that were gonna be the King
dude if my brother's gonna be the King
bro [ __ ] you guarantee I'll be out
fishing dude dang bro I ain't just gonna
hang out at the house and watch my
brother be king yeah boy
dude I'll grow my arms out and be out
there chase him huh you know or I would
arm dude my brother's a king I would be
up to no good I would get some neck
tattoos and probably get a Dodge Charger
and drive past the middle score that you
are the scene or the high school even
though I'm too old to be there and floor
it and make the ladies hot bra let the
ladies get that damp canal bro let him
tighten up when they see daddy roll by
if I was like very young I'm gonna talk
about now I'm saying if I was a young I
don't know what I'm talking about but
I'll tell you it is I'm happy to be home
and I'm happy to have been there thank
you very much England for the support
and for coming out dude it was crazy to
go to a place and have people come out
I'm gonna get right back into more but
first I got to tell you that if you sell
stuff
online you know if you sell things
you're probably still recovering from
the holiday shopping season well I have
a way to help you in 2020 and to help
make things less crazy and more
successful
it's called ship station ship station
makes managing and shipping out orders a
breeze you can import orders from any
sales channel ship with any carrier and
automate just about any shipping task
I've used ship station to ship goods
that we've sold through theof on store
I've used ship station of mail things to
my mother and it's got our nice gift
from Holland no matter where you're
selling Amazon Etsy your own website
ship station brings all your orders into
one simple interface ship station even
offers big discounts on shipping rates
you'll always know you're getting the
best deal get this year off to a great
start at ship station dot-com and use
the code Theo to get a 60 day free trial
that's two months free of no hassle
stress free shipping just visit ship
station calm click on the microphone at
the top of the page and type in Theo
that's ship station comm inter offer
code Theo make ship happen we got a call
that came in and I want to drop it on
you right here gang oh hey Theo it's
Rebecca
from London in England yesterday thank
you for calling Rebecca it very nice to
hear you call cheese me she is miss mom
alright sorry I've been practicing my
english on wood me my boyfriend came to
see your day time that are they say at
the chef is this empire and we loved it
what thank you very much that's really
that's nice to hear you saying you got a
beautiful accent to that accent out is
now on the women it sounds a nice and
you sound really really you sound
beautiful home word amazing
really good time we wanted to check
something out with you though since you
were walking offstage
out of sight we thought we saw you shake
your head and now this could have been
out of triumph or perhaps there was
somebody waiting in the sidelines that
you were happy to see but maybe you're
disappointed in something we don't know
but um we wanted to find out what you
thought about the show about your
reflections where I was general how you
sell the London firm is different from
your US funds anything really we also
had have taken a couple of 15 milligram
hitters just before so we could have got
this totally wrong another serious there
we did look we were sitting at the back
of level one and everyone around us is
having a good time we were having a good
time
please keep doing what you're doing we
love you same game Gang Gang madam wow
what a sweet call and even just hearing
your voice just reminds me suddenly it
takes me right back to being in England
and I'm sorry I'm sure you are a
beautiful lady in and now I feel
horrible about saying that about some of
the women but um you know you're right
actually the afternoon show in London
and I hadn't talked about London yet
London was a different experience than
Manchester London is very bustling it's
it's very diverse you have a lot of
different it just feels more worldly
it's huge
also every building I'm like is that
Buckingham Palace and people like nah
dude you know that's a Wendy's like dang
bro well Wendy's living Laura gay out
here papa
you know what I'm saying dude obviously
she moved on from that little law you
know she was being a probably a call
girl for old Dave Thomas and she moved
on and got herself a nice spot out here
no you're right though I was in London
and the afternoon show was tough
he's just like I feel like it started
off good and then I felt like it just I
don't know got a little tough and so at
the end I just I wasn't happy I was not
happy with myself on the way offstage
and it's so funny I do remember looking
at Ari because he's always standing
offstage when I get off and and just
shaking my head like dang so you're
right you're right about that
but I'm glad that you liked it I'm glad
to hear that that feedback you know
that's my brain you know I have the
brain that doesn't let me it always
finds something to not be you know it
chooses not to be proud of me instead
instead it chooses to give me these
other options first but I'm also a
perfectionist I want it to be great you
know I appreciate everybody who came out
even though I canceled on you guys or
adjusted chris d'elia cancels Bironas
can I believe that whether remember when
he canceled because of weather day wind
broke wind the wind is not anybody dude
you could cut a fan on right now and
cancel the show but that being said um
yeah it was just that was a tough one
that afternoon I think it's just the
afternoon dude nobody want it's hard to
do it in the afternoon it's hard to
pretend like 3:45 in the afternoon is
8:30 at night and that show I even did
more material than usual and just tried
to give you guys all I had but that
venue was hectic they weren't they
weren't allowing me to do
meet-and-greets there so that was a
tough thing it was what was the issue Oh
two of the show's we couldn't because of
the time and so I don't I guess I felt
like it would have been unfair but it
but London was cool man we went down I
had a friend one of my friends Kevin
came and visited me over in London
just friends nothing wild or nothing
like that not that there's anything
wrong with being wild if you're a gay
man that's great dude
good for you you know you did it
you know cuz anyway a lot of these
[ __ ] are driving a lot of us crazy so
I'm glad you got you know you found
something you like and and it look it's
kid scary sometimes you wonder you go to
another continent are you gonna be a gay
man there because I don't know the
exchange rate on sexuality who does you
know you can [ __ ] you can fly to
Nigeria and you know you wake up you a
damn you know you a 5/3 redhead in a
gangbang it just you don't we don't know
sometimes how it's going to shape out
but but I would be shocked if I was gay
man I would be I would be extremely
surprised bro if I was gay bro I would
be like are you sure because I would
just say would really I would be
extremely surprised but that's so
perceptive of you especially after you
was on them 15 milli hitters you and
your man out there and I hope y'all was
touching each other's bodies a little
because one thing I miss about getting
high is just touching my body or
touching somebody else's body female
body tit God bra makes you feel excited
huh but yeah that was a show I had a
tough time with that one and there was
one other one was it in Oslo I felt like
was kind of tough but we'll get there
we're still making our way we're making
our way across but yeah London was the
other one London is just here you go out
at night it's very posh and that means
fancy you know you'll see a guy some guy
dressed up like Ichabod Crane and then
you'll see somebody else [ __ ] you
know dressed up
like um like JCPenney or somebody you
know just it's really you know like
Donnie Nordstrom or something or [ __ ]
Sandra Marshalls they got everybody just
fancy you'll see a dude wearing a damn
train track or something you'll see a
guy wearing uh he's got a jacket made
out of [ __ ] worms you know 14-karat
gold
actual worms you're like Dana what's
going on you know I'll go fishing with
that jacket I'll catch a big I'll catch
Moby Dick on a 6,000 pound test line bro
I'm going in I'm going in um what else
happening in London that's it that's it
that I really remember you know it does
you you also start to remember where
time started and everything and where
you know or basically where white time
started you like you know you're in the
UK and you see people from you know
Ireland and you're like oh okay the name
Megan you know you hear the name
somebody's like oh this is Megan you're
like oh I know now I see where Megan
started where the name came from or
you'll hear um you know Cara you're like
oh okay
Cara we said Cara but I see this is
where or maybe that's just the accent I
don't know but there were things you're
like oh okay
I see how this we're doing this in
America but it started here you know
it's just like going to your
grandparents house and seeing the
pictures on the wall you're like oh okay
that's where I'm came from oh yeah I
remember uncle Ronnie yeah I remember
him yeah oh yeah yeah he had two wooden
arms bro and he used to [ __ ] play the
drums dude of course he did but you're
like yeah yeah I remember and everything
is like a artifact everything is
historical
and they got beef - United Kingdom it
should be like yeah yeah cuz they got a
beef in man
Britain's Briggs it in the other
Scotland is divvied up and they got
north Scotland or North I somebody got
[ __ ] they're trying to get their own
[ __ ] the Scottish you know Ireland
they're partying bro dude Ireland man
those people are some happy people
there's some happy people man and the
band played on brother and we moved on
and I didn't know what to talk to people
about over there so you know me I'm
talking about [ __ ] the only things I
know Revolutionary War Titanic so that
was the toughest part about being in the
United Kingdom was just some of the
conversation and Charles Dickens or
Chuck dick a lot of people called him
when I was growing up Chuck dick was
also a PDF file about two towns over
over from Slidell Louisiana and I never
met him but I heard about him one of the
more popular PDF files when I was young
but all right let's move on we got into
some other places and some other music
and the next place we went to was
Scotland Glasgow
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and that is some Scottish music right
there
by a band Trabant 33 Travon 33 with that
hit right there
okay you get to Glasgow and it's uh it's
a lot of hills and it's raining and it's
about 55 degrees Fahrenheit and it's
raining even when it's not ready if it's
not raining a lot people call that
sunshine like it would just be raining a
little and people like all man it's
beautiful we're having a wedding today
I'm like whoa ha your no wedding out
here you're gonna have a half inch of
rain you know a half inch of rain at the
nuptials brother god it's beautiful the
food and the accident got if in Britain
it was like oh you want you don't and
then in Ireland it was like
[Music]
and then you got to Glasgow and people
wasn't even one guy just talked in all
just all Elle's encagement
you're the mayor
but the people of Glasgow man right when
you're look in their eyes they're
beautiful
they're good people man they're good
people in there they have cigarettes
even for breakfast you see a
six-year-old over there banging out a
you know a door I'll you know are you'll
[ __ ] you'll slip but you know you'll
reach up the sleeve of a nine year old
girl and she'll have two Winston's in
there and a thing of cinnamon gum like
name all right they staying warm out
here and in Glasgow you would a lot of
the men if you were out and about at
night the men get real close you think
at all the men are gay but it's just
because they're friendly
you see 9 dudes hugging each other
around the neck and you're like dang
everybody's loves men here's me you know
the women they never gonna have any you
know little chickadees because the men
are just you know just loving each other
but it's just friendship it is just
friendship but you can't tell because
they're just such mates they call it
mates and checkmate that's when you
either playing chess or you actually are
fully on you know you full-on homosexual
and that's beautiful man isn't it
everything is great about that if you're
homosexual bro then you did it you know
so that's great but yeah the Scottish
man it was great we went out in Glasgow
I put a video of it on my Instagram and
it was just electric
it was electric and then hung out in
Glasgow for two days
oh and yeah just kind of dreary rainy
stated a nice place there though is a
nice so nicest hotel we stayed in and
the people of Glasgow man just walking
up and down hill just you know just
getting it done eating haggis and I
think that's basically - I don't want to
say it's I think haggis is like this
stomach or em it's like the damn
whatever connects your stomach to your
nuts bro that's what it is
and it's Scottish and they they eat it
so no wonder they drink I drink too if I
eat that if I had a [ __ ] half you know
if I had to painful to somebody else's
nuts I'm having a Michelob light bro no
doubt about it and yeah I heard they had
a lot of cocaine in Scotland I didn't
have any but that was like a popular
export that I heard about I think it
protects specific I mean that was just
that was the UK it was a lot of I mean
it was just great it was just a lot of
go go go people think oh did you travel
did you get on a camel did you do
anything man I didn't by the time you
get off stage at night there's no place
is open to eat you got to find a spot to
eat and next thing you know it's 1:00
a.m. and you got to get up early and
cruise and so that was just a vibe it
was a lot of go go go but thank you guys
so much over there for coming out in the
UK and man I'll say this everybody Oh
big dis dude ginger monkey came out the
biggest dude I ever seen and his buddies
I have him he could eat a banana without
even using his own hands he could peel
it right out of there with his teeth and
everything and his buddies kept having
him do it the two probably had [ __ ]
nine bananas after the show and I was
like yeah I put him in the zoo bro do
whatever you got to do I think the guy
could be homoerotic
you know this guy could be the mayor of
West Hollywood in probably 45 minutes
all he need is one good YouTube video
but that was that man oh yeah well a lot
of for the breakfast they had a lot of
like meat like you somebody give you a
cutter you know nine little cuts of beef
for breakfast I wouldn't he'll you know
every meal seemed like you read like you
were in the military like a little pot
of beans and a little some hard piece of
bread and uh like what is this like like
oh it's it's it's the UK mate and that
was more in Britain but but the people
were great man across the board over
there and I love you guys and thank you
so much for coming out and just making
me feel welcome even after I couldn't
make it in the first time is September
yeah and here let's take a call we'll
take a call that came in and we'll get
to some other things but yeah you were
right about that young lady I was I was
shaking my head after that show and for
some reason the afternoon was tough I
never did a show in there I never did it
even in that evening or the afternoon
deal I never did it and now I did it so
let's take this hitter right here again
I was just calling because I knew you
were gonna be in Europe this week and I
just wanted to see if you tried those
cheddar and onion chips and Dublin me
and my wife one time we got to go there
and the bartender suggested these things
and they're so good and I don't even
remember a base but cheddar and onion
potato chips vo you got a trial dude and
if you do tell me what you thought about
oh man I love you Gang Gang Gang brother
yeah thank you for calling I didn't I
didn't I just got the message today from
you but the I didn't I don't know if I
had the chips or not I don't remember
what I had I had some eggs I remember
and they got some birds over there yeah
they you know they're taking
eggs off of old school birds out of a
ostrich out of a damn stork you're like
[ __ ]
you know they got eggs out the Bible
over there they got old school food over
there and they give you a little pot of
beans with everything oh you can't read
here's a pot of beans all your cousin
lost his limb out there in a fire here's
a pot of beans for you oh you never seen
Breaking Bad here's a pot of beans mine
was you know doing uni yeah the British
it's like everybody's keeping a secret
but nobody will tell you it's almost
like you're at a Funeral but nobody will
tell you who died that's the vibe I got
like this kind of sullen sort of like
everybody was playing a game a clue but
no one ever even opened the board the
box so you're like where who's Colonel
Mustard everybody it's just I don't know
but you know I think everything's cool
between us in them I think overall
everything's cool nobody nobody one girl
at a bar got offended that were from
America and I don't know what she was
upset about but this honestly bruh if
she got upset because we're from America
she got she got she was upset before
that her parents were probably both
upset whenever they were making love to
make her so young man um and then the
next place we went to was Amsterdam and
before I tell you about it I have to
tell you that I have been taking care of
my crotch and if you listen real close
you can't hear a lot of wind going past
my crotch because there's not a lot of
hair around it at the moment and support
for this past weekend comes from
manscaped who is the best and men's
below-the-belt grooming manscaped offers
precision
engineered tools for your family jewels
it's 2020 and you know what that means
new year new me new balls new balls
hairy bushes are so 2019 guys some guys
you'll see they have those thighs you
notice those thighs have these long
straps of hair on them get out of here
it's nasty buddy and I use um man
escapes different tools that they have
to take care of my body and even my legs
and knees I get hair also on the back of
my knees dude cuz obviously someone in
my family was in a gir manscaping
accidents are a thing of the past
man's cape makes it easy with their
grooming products you shouldn't use the
same trimmer on your balls that you do
on your face it's just dirty manscaped
has the crop preserver and anti chafing
ball deodorant and moisturizer you
already put do it on your armpits put it
on your harm pit your wiener Invo get
20% off free shipping with code theo at
manscaped dot-com start the new year off
the right way by using the best tools
for the job your ball or balls will
thank you not everyone has two balls get
20% off and free shipping with the code
theo at manscape comm that's 20% off
with Free Shipping at manscaped calm and
use code th e Oh onward to Amsterdam
[Music]
and that is a hit from Amsterdam high
six is the name of that band hy SICS
with that regional hit called made in
Amsterdam and that's a strong you can
feel the beat in there you can feel the
undertones and the the different
overtones as well Amsterdam the Dutch
baby the Dutch by far some of the most
aerodynamic people you'll ever see I
mean they're the Dutch are downhill
they're downhill individuals they will
they are in motion IMD baby the in
motion does you don't see a lot of still
Dutch name 70 still Dutch
nobody can brother okay they're in
motion doesn't matter they're on a tram
they're on rollerskates they're sewing a
magic carpet and riding on it at the
same time the Dutch are doing things if
you don't have any missiles Phil you
freaking Dutch buddy's mouth up with
gunpowder and send him on his way bruh
he'll get the job done they are movers
tell someone in Amsterdam to keep a
secret no problem there they will never
stop long enough to even share what you
told them I mean everywhere you go in
Amsterdam they're just get on a train on
a bike on a boat on a bird on a rumor on
a breeze just
[Music]
the Dutch are coming and going I saw a
dude pass by on a falcon putting on skis
and worried he was gonna be late for a
regional avalanche they are on the move
where are you going brother
others a ship you know there's a
unicycle there's a bycicle doxycycline
Rocky Johnson I'm catching him he's
headed to heaven um yeah
gotta catch the 5:00 train man to a
canoe to a goober pool that actually
drains into a real pool and it's a
whirlpool and then I'm meeting Joran van
der Sloot and hopefully the Bermuda
Triangle will still be open because we
got to be there I can't believe they let
people get high there okay there's way
too many moving parts it's almost like
trying to smoke a blunt in the middle of
a game of Tetris on difficult I mean I
can't being high they're just everywhere
they're just it'd be like being high in
a like a in a conveyor belt Factory bruh
I found nah maybe you know catch me I'll
be in the hammock area but Amsterdam
they the Dutchman I'm saying I'm telling
you their aerodynamic for a reason
because they're on the move
and look if you see if you see a Dutch
person this is how you see them that's a
Dutch Oh what's oh what's that oh that's
a Dutch oh dang oh man
what was it Oh a Dutch you what was that
oh dang Oh
[Music]
what say Allah is that hail naw that's a
batch of Dutch son the Dutch are coming
and going they're in motion whoa
somebody just pulled the floor out from
under me
nah that's the shifts on this plate
tectonic Dutch beautiful city beautiful
people but you got to be ready to move
to move everything's in you know even
the cows there they run and bra they not
graze and they'll do too
you'll see a cow jump over the moon dude
and do it a couple times that day yeah
everything they're on the go you get a
steak at night there's no meat on it
this cow damn who's just Kyra Lewis this
thing ran right out of his own meat and
the steak be like a damn nugget bro like
a beef nugget you could throw it up in
the air and that's nothing bro you know
you got a mouthful of a hamster steak
stay Dutch baby stay Dutch all right
let's take another call that came into
the hotline Oh Sofia
quick question for you what do you were
your thoughts on the candle that a
Gwyneth Paltrow brought out there
supposedly smells like her vagine whoo
yeah look here's the thing if we can
sell the candle then at a certain point
you're gonna you I think you're gonna
have to legalize prostitution because
here's the thing you put that in your
window some guy stops by you know some
guy climbs in your window with an
erection yeah he's not in the right but
you know we're creatures
and we have senses you know we have up
to five senses and um you can't you know
you can't say you selling whale meat and
I get there and they got no [ __ ]
blubber and the cupboard you feel me if
you put two titties on the side and I
show up for uh let me think some titty
you can't get all pissed so that's the
thing you throw a couple of vag Andals
out there and somebody shows up wanting
a little bit of serving of uh you know
cooter cat you can't don't be shocked
yeah you know don't be shocked don't be
shocked if an OB GYN shows up at your
door with some you know tongs or
whatever I don't know what they even use
probably not I mean something just don't
be shocked you know you got a vag Andale
are you light of a Jan turn in your yard
don't be shocked when a couple of
Dobermans and heat show up you know or a
couple of um you know maybe a local
soccer team they're running doing doing
laps around the block and they beeline
over and bring a couple of fricken
everybody's got their own goalposts you
know what I'm saying you know what's
next they're gonna have probably vagina
might people aren't sure you know
somebody lights that and throws it
somewhere and everybody thinks that some
local lady ruined everything you know
and then next thing is sofa Gesell's bra
you know the militaries they shootin for
Gesell's over there into the Middle East
and then things land and they already
hate women but now their noses are going
make them think they have reason to you
know their you know the verge essence
that's going to be left in the air is
going to tell them that they are
justified and that's enough words I
think but yeah I don't know when does it
stop
III think Gwyneth didn't think of this
through so but thank you for the call
brother I appreciate that all right let
me tell you one more thing that I need
to tell you right now and that is about
Skillshare it's the time of year where
you need to look real hard into the
mirror are you happy with where you are
I don't know if I am I don't think I am
did you make the right choices with your
life are you the person you want to be I
mean dang these are some real hard
questions but the answer really is
simple and that is Skillshare make 2020
year where you explore new skills deep
in existing passions and get lost in
creativity with skill shares online
classes would you find might just
surprise and inspire you personally I'm
taking Simon cynics how to share ideas
that inspire action because it's
important if you're trying to
communicate with somebody you want to do
it well you don't want to be talking to
somebody about architecture and then
they you know next thing you know they
don't know how to you know they trying
to make a pizza you're like what
you know they trying to order a pizza or
something from hot wings or whatever
anyway Skillshare offers classes
designed for real life so you can move
your creative journey forward without
putting life on hold you can learn and
grow with short classes that fit your
busy routine film and video music and
video production productivity and
finance and more skills share is also
incredibly affordable especially when
compared to pricey in-person classes and
workshops an annual subscription is less
than $10 a month unlimited unlimited
capabilities at the touch of your
fingertips
or that can be at the touch of the
fingertips of someone who has fingertips
that need skills explore your creativity
at Skillshare comm / Theo von and get
two free months of premium membership
that's two months free at Skillshare
comm / Theo von get skills and thank you
for supporting this past weekend thank
you guys all for your support it's just
uh it's nice I'm a lucky man and just
that's one thing I noticed after the
show's going over there in Europe was
just the same it's the same people that
come out to the shows the value of just
just loving good people
now we're podcast listeners you know the
stand-up is a different thing I love
stand-up is my job I mean but you know
podcasting has become a universe for me
it's become for us you know it's just
the amount of people that I meet that
are just so supportive of me man thank
you you know it means a lot to have
somebody care it means a lot and and
just the fact that you know that my
higher power has given me people that
care on such a level where I get to meet
so many of them it really just inspires
me a lot you know it inspires me a lot
not to give up on things when I want to
so yeah I just feel pretty blessed and
and I hope that you can feel that too
sometimes and I hope to be able to do
whatever I can to be a part of making
your life feel good and most of the time
it does a lot of times you know I think
we we're thinking too much and you guys
remind me of that a lot of people say me
just being too hard on yourself
and this and that but just also does so
many fun people then we came out we
showed out man thinking of somebody that
came to one of the shows this gentleman
came to the show down there in Lafayette
let's take a peek what oh boy Jeb and
brought off the Georgia actually came up
what's up Jeff over there in Valdosta
and Valdosta I mean that's a place that
Valdosta Georgia something could get a
damn biscuit there this better make you
freakin bile and locally that's how good
it is I bet gang homework saw your sewin
last year and I showed you a picture of
the little camper 1964 model camper I
would say and then over there and my
girlfriend wasn't having it but oh yes
look we got a um I'm gonna get this and
I'm gonna put it in here yes dude
onward she had to stay there because we
had to go through you and now you told
me to send it to Instagram softer guys
stand the video I uploaded a video for
premature and Nick to get to you as a
nice little video of it to the cool
little place right he stayed in at two
nights and I think she she enjoyed it
more she said she did but okay he's
sucking mouth sex right there
homeward yeah she enjoyed the show she's
always giving me afeard about watching
his podcast all the time but funny thing
is she posted on the ride home she
posted a video or a picture saying that
she had become a fan at the Obon and she
thoroughly enjoyed the show so you got a
new fan out of that and she got me to
coffee mode that this past weekend
coffee mug oh no Christmas book a
gravelly good New Year and having fun
over in Europe brothers love you love
you too man thanks bro man it's so nice
of you dude that's nice of you to come
out yeah I'm gonna um we're gonna edit
that video in I'm gonna peek at it in a
second but thank you man thank you and
thank you for bringing out your lady she
sounds like a nice lady and I'm glad you
guys went
have fun let's look at this picture this
joint yes bro if you guys are on YouTube
you can see what's going on here and
this is a very limited style cubic I'll
right here they got this that pink and
white that two-tone he got her a picture
of eyes on the back and the eyes are
like the eyes that every kid draws when
they're like in kindergarten who's not
going to be a good artist or like second
grade there's always kids who were gonna
be a good artist and they draw like a
damn you know Mona and Lisa and then the
rest of us draw a damn [ __ ] shotgun
Sally out there with two eyes and it's
all it's all we could do in the eyebrows
and then we kind of give up a little bit
in the nose and mouth look bad but yeah
this man look at this pictures right
here let's see oh there we are right
there with Dustin the diamond Poirier
right there man what a great night that
was man we raised some money for a good
fight foundation and we did all that
together man that was cool you know it
was part of me sometimes even when I was
the one doing the fundraisers and then
uh that doesn't want to be sharing that
doesn't want to be caring man you know
that wants to be just I don't know
that's the dark arts bro but then I see
this picture man it makes me feel good
look you and your girls smiling
beautiful lady
both y'all looking [ __ ] finest [ __ ]
really bruh oh damn there's me right
there kissing your lady on the cheek uh
hold on we got Oki text to that came in
this is a camper guy he's sending in
what's up Nick here are the pictures and
videos in 1964 camper I didn't ever pick
up the tarp on top in the Airbnb listing
damn Airbnb and here's a pic of Theo
kissing my lady and staring me in the
eye bro you know what I'm saying that's
how we do it
the chickens weren't in the listing
either but they were a nice addition the
dude that owned it also had cocktail
hour every night bet he did and played
his homemade
on the front porch and Knicks that we
have a video of that here let's see that
action Jackson okay here's the cottage
right here we go front of Maryland
monitor unit oh yeah yes how they got
indoors and outdoors huh that's
beautiful the tires are flat yet you
can't being on a roll anywhere I do the
Dutch would hate it the Dutch would hate
it let's see if we get them music here's
a hit of the music that the man did yeah
this might have to be one of the best
Airbnb listings ever and that's not a
KTN that's that that's that a bootleg
zydeco that's that cement zydeco right
there because it's got a little bit of
Spanish moss in the pipes but he's also
it sounds a little bitter band right
there but when we're head of that when
it has a very Scottish vibe to man the
SCOTUS are basically like Louisiana in
England that's what it's like just a lot
of good people man in the Irish
everybody's good but I'm just saying you
get over to Scotland you have somebody
who have a cigarette for breakfast bro
you know what'd you have for breakfast
oh I had nine derails baby you know what
I'm saying in the Easter Egg people you
know they real religious around there
you'll have somebody dude they grilling
up they got peanut butter sandwich but
both ends its body of Christ bro and PB
in the middle do and you never put jelly
on the Lord so back that sweeten around
it air bro gang let me see how we get
your lady sent in a video to thank you
for this I'm Jeff helps me all the way
here in Lafayette Louisiana and a
goddang trailer
like camper damn bruh yeah she sounds
real pleased brother I will say that if
you guys get a chance to check out the
YouTube you got to see this place that
Marilyn Monroe Airbnb listing there out
there very rare very rare in Lafayette
let's get into the last places we went
on the tour and the next place we went
to was Oslo Norway and that's that
banger right there called national
anthem Warks wor X and in Norway it was
it was bright outside for maybe 50
minutes a day Norway and Sweden you
hadn't there was literally you could be
eating cereal at breakfast and if you
took a long time to eat it it was
bedtime that's what there was
I think people went to work for maybe 40
minutes it was just it's if you like -
there's not a lot it's a good place if
you like to read if you want to read go
to Norway great place to just you
haven't read some you need to catch up
on maybe I don't know 600 books maybe
you didn't do the you know 5th through
eleventh grade Norway you got time to
read it's easier to read it away if you
can't even read go to Norway cuz you can
it is oh it's just a good place to read
and a lot of like Viking type of people
too you see a lot of men with long hair
beautiful women
Amsterdam had beautiful women but yeah
you see like a lot of a lot of people
you know English is definitely more
secondary language there so you have
they use a lot of F's and J's and their
words like I did I was in a conversation
I didn't know what I couldn't tell if I
was friends with somebody or or if I
just like bought car insurance I had no
idea what was going on
deeply for the DDT
liebelei all they would do somehow it
would be like I didn't I thought I you
know you thought you you just met
somebody and next thing you know they
you know they give you $40 or something
and they take your necklace off your
neck like why what just happened here
yeah there were just some of the
exchanges you didn't know what was going
on and dude you could hurt your neck
saying a word one guy he got stuck
singing something he was like foolishly
4G for you for you and I I had to
[ __ ] pat him on the back real hard
and two boiled eggs [ __ ] came out of
his mouth bruh it just does a lot at you
do you put you throw your back out
finishing a long sentence dude they got
and everybody in Norway has a backpack
on they got these people I don't know
what's going on I mean I guess they just
you never know when you might end up on
a mountain you never know they got a
backpack they got ice pick fresh water
salt water cold water they got all kind
of water new water old water water water
they got waters daughter dude just wet
[ __ ] rolling by like dying this lady I
don't even know what's going on dude and
they had also
and a lot of these countries they got
the same type of dude I grew up with
Daniel brah you'll see him in different
countries he's got on a Dutch hat over
there and he's got a windmill over there
and he's using it to just you know to
help him [ __ ] get harder hits off of
a vape you know you'll see him over
there in Amsterdam and they call him
Amsterdam yo brah and he's out there
throwing mushroom do give him mushrooms
- uh you know - just throwing him into
the mouths at a passing Dutch you know
when he's training goldfish do with a
small wand so it just you know the dark
art store brought out the dark hearts
themselves in the last place we ended up
in was a stockholm stockholm and oh I
had reindeer I have reindeer do what you
have him for dinner
Oh Prancer dude let me get a couple of
them [ __ ] Prancer medallions bro you
know throw me 40 kilograms of Cupid over
there and um you know throw it in a soup
we'll do a bouillabaisse boy damn he
throw [ __ ] - jingle bells in this
flank steak son and we doing it and
that's brave as hell Stockholm y'all
eaten rain dear watch out what else
y'all having over there hey let me get a
couple of them are ya Care Bears yeah
let me get a couple of them Oh mother
Goose yeah I'll take two of her eggs for
breakfast yeah let me get that um let me
get a little bit of Care Bear jerky oh
yeah I'll take some let me get seven
pounds of it you know how many Care
Bears have to take a perma L so you can
have seven pounds of CBJ bruh yeah but
they had reindeer and I ordered it
and you get a small like that's the
saddest part you get a leg it's about a
foot long you're like damn this thing I
mean they killed it a lower lebra you
could have at least let that thing
mustache the size or whatever you could
at least let it heighten out at least
let it play JV I mean this thing they
took its life early the whole leg you
can see right from hoof to uh to but
probably about eleven inches like day
this little reindeer this thing hadn't
even played this thing hadn't worked for
Santa this thing hadn't even worked for
Delta probably you know this thing was
in the prelims if anything this thing
was probably helping out a local crop
duster I mean this was a small Rd bra
and it came and looked I hate to say it
but I had it and reindeer look at me man
look at me over here to and back over
here it's good it's good
if you don't think reindeers good then
you shouldn't think reindeer is good it
tastes like beef went to college bro
that's what it tastes like it's a very
organized meat of course it is dude you
know it's built to shuffle gifts across
the universe so you can't come into that
all haphazardly you know wag you ain't
got [ __ ] on this little [ __ ] you know
on one of the Lord's you know seven
favorite gift horses so I don't know
what it was you know I don't know if you
want a couple you know you want a couple
of Prancer medallions or you want to you
know you want the burnt ends of Blitzen
whatever you want they got it so the
Swedes man Oh
it's I can't believe y'all are doing it
but yes that is that is the darkest of
arts when you take something out of a
children's you know what's next which
what else what else is on the menu
Clifford the Big Red Dog nuggets what
else is on the menu Sweden Peppa the pig
pate uh-huh which what else y'all servin
uh just uh just uh a kielbasa of
children's dreams
and that's Sweden man and that's Sweden
and that's showing Stockholm was that
was fire that was fire and look some of
it look you know everything was great
man I'm not trying to sound ungrateful
they were all great I'm just trying to
be honest with you about how I feel
about those shows about how I feel but
you know my brain I have that terminal
thing that always wants to kick me in
the in the D you know my brain my ego
puts on big boots every morning just to
kick me right in the frickin D bro gang
man let's take another call here here we
go Oh Thomas man yeah oh man I used to
know somebody named Thomas do hell I
used to know probably six people named
Thomas man so so that's awesome and more
over podcast again I thought about how
interesting it was they trying to get a
perspective you know not from a big-name
person but from everyday man I just
thought it'd be kind of interesting I'm
kind of biased but I'm a
firefighter/paramedic and I just thought
it'd be cool if you have oh that's dope
man my friend is a paraplegic and he um
what else does he do he does he does a
lot of different [ __ ] but sorry homeward
had any buddies that were like maybe
like doctors or nurses or you know farm
and EMTs or something - oh yeah we're
gonna get some different people in man I
appreciate that suggestion man to get
kind of maybe get one of them you guys
on the ship because I know I've got some
pretty interesting stories and I love
hearing other people's stories I think
you know like our first responder type
of dude or even like a Subway sandwich
artist would be
oh I love that idea that Subway sandwich
artists broke because most of those
shops get a be that food B yeah first
responder what about that last responder
that's what I'm talking about they don't
talk about that guy that shows up about
30 minutes late to a cardiac arrest you
know and he's oh they're huffing down a
Winston bra and complaining about his
stepmother damn bra that's what I'm
talking about that last responder I'm
talking about lassie Drake you know what
I'm saying who shows up over there two
hours late you know and he [ __ ] he
and he forgot his work shirt so he's
dressed just in personal clothing you
know he's dressed just in a cincinnati
bengals jersey and he's trying to do CPR
on you you're like damn man I bet look
I've been fine I healed up I healed up
45 minutes ago you know that's what I'm
talking about I'm talking about old
Deborah you know who's a little much on
the outside of the age range to be a
first responder you know when she gets
caught up over there she forgets to keep
the walkie-talkie volume up because it
hurts her it makes her shingles flare up
so she shows up you know maybe 45 or 60
minutes late to um you know to a house
fire and she's over there trying to tell
you you know tell y'all shouldn't be
smoking cigarettes you know like what
are you talking about this was from a
space heater seven people died and she's
like all right you know well I'm gonna
read my Reader's Digest over there about
a truck you don't say I'm talking about
these last responders that's what I'm
talking about where does where they at
the real people bro I'm talking about
the bootleg ambulance dude who shows up
because he keeps that scanner and he
rolls up you know eight for $40 brah
gets you to the UH
you feel me for $40 I get you to Urgent
Care brah you know you could bring two
people with you that's a fight I'll up
charge right there yeah so that's what
I'm talking about
that's what I'm talking about you know
I'm talking about Big Willie I'm talking
about Big Willie in the church van he's
like well I take you over there man
God wants you well brother I'll take
care of it
you know he'll we'll stop at my cousin's
house you know make me up make up uh
mirliton casserole grill up uh grill up
a pumpkin you ever had a hamburger
stuffed pumpkins and I what son what are
you talking about that I broke both of
my legs and I fell off a building he's
like all this free man it's free you
know I'm working with the church some of
some of these last responders that's who
I want to know about that's who I wanted
to know about what else we got man
everything came in cool I'll see you
guys this weekend I'm going to be in
Denver Colorado
I think that's sold out we got Las Vegas
coming up January 31st and February 1st
those are that's in Las Vegas yeah Gold
Country Casino Oroville Casino February
15th and then the Queen Elizabeth
Theatre in Toronto for February 20th
that's kind of what's going on right now
oh that's the I think we got through
that's Europe I mean there's so much
more to it but we did it and I just and
I tried man we tried our best man we got
out I was taking cold showers before the
shows just to make sure my energy was up
you know when we did it we got through
it you know we got through it and and
just yeah getting to meet people were so
nice people you know brought out some
gifts I got if somebody brought me a
little pair of shoes for a child
somebody got me um a couple things a
candy art my boy McCloskey dude one of
the best and worst artists in in Ireland
hit me up with that home stretch piece I
got this from Trinity College I got this
adult fitness band that I have on my
head
and this is for kind of snow fitness and
that kind of thing and yeah I would come
back I would come back in a heartbeat
and just the vibe that everybody had of
like hey thank you for coming here man
it was cool you know I'm just grateful
man and I tried my best to make the
stories fun and and and just to be a
part of y'all's lives and thank you very
much for welcoming me over there uh all
right let's get out of here today man
you guys be good to yourselves we'll be
back this week we got Bobby Lee coming
in um we got some other great guests
coming up really excited about it it's
gonna be a big year King and the sting
is back this week and everything is okay
you know and thank you guys for making
me feel okay and don't give up on
yourselves you know we got this we'll be
okay
you know everything is gonna be cool
and I love you you know and I do love
you and you know thanks for staying as
shitty Airbnb ease or not shitty ones
but just unique Airbnb ease to come out
and be a part of my dream and and to be
part of stuff that that this past
weekend is a part of it means a lot and
and I sit man be good to yourselves you
deserve it and good to be back in
America you know people want to curse a
lot of people want to curse America
right now and stuff because of different
things and to me that is crazy man you
know it's just I don't know how some
people I don't know it just doesn't help
us I don't know what I want to say some
people but it doesn't help us to live
somewhere and to be
I'm grateful for it you know the news
wants us to be so angry man but our
hearts don't I believe that man our
hearts do not are you guys be good to
your sales man we'll uh we'll head out
of here on that some of that old
Scottish town gang
[Music]
you